speaking of public opinion about the
president
uh donald trump has been accused by yet
another woman of sexual assault
this time during the presidential
campaign these are not accusations from
the eighties
or accusations from the nineties as many
accusations about donald trump have been
these are recent claims her name is alva
johnson
she says that donald trump grabbed her
by the hand when he left an rv
outside of a tampa florida rally on
august 24
2016 and leaned in to kiss her on the
lips
a kiss that was unwanted by alva and
that she turned her head
and the kiss landed on the side of her
mouth
the white house is denying it saying
simply this didn't happen
some people are asking why didn't she
come forward before
if this happened her lawyers are saying
she didn't come forward before
because she was bound by one of those
oppressive non-disclosure agreements
that donald trump is known
for pushing on people in his private
life
in his work life and in his political
life
of course we may never know the truth
about any individual incident
specifically as a result of so many of
these ndas
but it's now a very very long list of
people that have accused
donald trump it goes all the way back to
trump's ex-wife
ivana who says trump raped her back in
nineteen eighty nine
jill hearth accused trump for actions in
nineteen ninety two
summers servos in two thousand seven
related to the filming of the apprentice
all three of whom have court filings to
go with their allegations
and then there's this whole litany of
women whose names we have up on the
screen
uh jessica leeds in the nineteen
eighties christian anderson in the
nineties kathy heller
in ninety seven temple tiger mcdowell
in the nineties uh carina virginia
mindy mcgill revay mcgillivray rachel
crooks and natasha stoiniff we've heard
about former fox news anchor juliet
huddy's take
jessica drake nini laxanan cassandra
searles
a number of miss teen usa contestants
making extraordinarily disturbing
allegations about trump's presence in
their
locker room or dressing room up bridget
sullivan
tasha dixon samantha holby and this is
probably only
a partial list so it's really really bad
and then on top of this and i hope to
get to it this week
there are child rape allegations
with uh um in sort of in conspiracy with
a guy named
jeffrey epstein that are vile vile and
disturbing to read
and we may soon know more about that uh
it's almost like trump just told the
truth
when he talked about hey you just grab
women by the [ __ ]
uh he seems to slip up and tell the
truth that seems to be trump's mo
he says hey you know what i did fire
james comey to stop the russia
investigation that that's true it's
obstruction
he says hey i i just grab women i grab
women wherever it is i want to do it
it's true and more than a dozen women
say that he did exactly that and i want
to remind you because this is just
so uh the contrast is incredible
billy bush the guy who was on that
access hollywood
recording with donald trump billy bush
was fired merely for being a part of the
conversation
about grabbing by the [ __ ] okay trump
is
president along with more than a dozen
specific named allegations of sexual
assault and misconduct against him
will there be consequences the answer is
probably not uh but it's still important
for every single alleged victim of
donald trump's
to be able to tell the story and as
these uh non-disclosure agreements
um start to be broken or don't hold up
i would not be even remotely surprised
if we start hearing more and more of
these allegations
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram while you're there
at david pakman we will take a break the
great cass
sunstein joins me next to talk about his
new book on freedom
which is uh out today we got cass
sunstein
on the day of his book release will
speak to him next
one of today's sponsors is privacy.com
pacman this is a free service that i've
actually been using myself for a while
now and i love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or
bank account to privacy.com's mobile app
or browser extension for firefox and
chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting
your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button
you have the ability to create multiple
virtual cards delete cards freeze and
unfreeze cards you can put a limit on a
card
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to
and it protects you from being hacked it
protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial
somewhere if you don't want your real
credit card number
to be exposed and on file and their app
and browser extension
let you autofill the virtual credit card
number into the credit card field
when you're buying things online there
are a ton of different advantages to
shopping and paying bills with a system
like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted
and in some situations you can earn five
percent cash back on your purchases
it's all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets
five dollars towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below